okay go
they gave me a gavel this time it's
pretty good so um welcome everybody uh
we're going to call the meeting to
order uh I guess first thing we're going
to do is
uh do a pledge um want to help us
please flag the United
States Nation
thank
you um everybody got a copy of the
minutes in the mail from the last
meeting um are there any um well do a
motion I need a motion to approve the
minutes please move to
approve Senator Lang I need a
second l l okay Senator Del second uh
any
discussion
okay seeing none all in favor of
approving the minute say I I opposed no
you guys have it okay the minutes are
approved uh since the last meeting uh
we um we we we got the we got three
proposals in from uh three vendors uh to
be our Consultants to to look at some of
the key issues that we want to addressed
and uh a subcommittee of Senator Lang
Charlie McIntyre and myself uh met um
interestingly enough we all read the the
proposals and they were
Innovation convergence and then
spectrum and um I did I did send a
summary to everybody about the process
that we did uh but I started off this
like being in a jury um I said let's
just have a first round of who who would
you pick as number one
and all three of us said spectrum and
then we went through a more detailed
process uh of that and it turns out
Spectrum was actually the low bid at
77,500 plus
travel Innovation was 8
80,000 and convergence was 123,000 and
change um but and then we used the
process uh the Charlie has that he uses
to to assess these things weighted
74% uh um qualifications and then 25%
the price and and it scored out that uh
Spectrum was the firm so we did um and
then I sent an email to everybody I said
it's you know in L of having a meeting
get approval I said does anybody object
please let me know uh no one objected so
we we started the ball rolling with
Spectrum but Charlie can you give us an
update as to where we are cuz you know
we need a contract or something like
important uh yeah so
the we're in the process now um that
it's with Spectrum waiting for them to
sign off on it so and after that I think
really they're just dealing the the
ministerial matters of the state the
Secretary of State sign off and so they
they they've got a a contract in our
language yes yeah yeah okay and so when
we get that back we'll submit it through
GNC approval
right you know yeah because post haste
yeah it has to be post haste because you
know time is clicking here and we need
them for the two big issues that we're
going to address one is is the
allocation of the money
appropriate between the between the the
state Charities and the and the uh
facilities and um and then you know the
oversight the regulation part uh we
wanted to compare us compare us to these
other states that have you know bigger
casinos so those are the two major
things other little things there too but
those are the main things so we it' be
helpful to get them going on this so we
can then use their respon their
observations to drive our discussions
about that and for us to come to some
conclusions that we need to modify or
whatever what we're doing so um
hopefully what's the drop dead for
getting the executive Council for
March is it end I think you said seg
midm march to to submit and then yeah
Kelly yeah yeah there's a calendar it's
only days ahead of the I'll have to
check okay because I is that next
meeting the 27th okay no the next the
27th will be the following meeting be
the first one in April
yeah so okay let's think you that so but
we're on it we're trying to get it
moving um what I'd like to try to do and
I'm going to talk to to Charlie offline
is even though we may not have a
contract I I think it may not be a bad
idea especially if they've signed off in
the contract I think it's 99% I don't
understand 90% 99% sure that the
executive council is not going to say no
that I'd like to have them at
least next meeting they have said no
before one two commissions ago they
denied the contract for a
consultant so just preparing
you I love that this but I'm sure they
wouldn't mind uh zooming into our our
meeting so that we can start at least
having discussions with
them um I
think you know we didn't ask them to
come in and and I remember I was a
consultant for 43 years we just have to
come in we'd have to defend our
proposals in front of whatever we never
had that part part of it so I I don't
think they would mind us zooming them in
and having them fly in here to um just
talk to us about we we I'm sure we all
have questions about how this is all
going to work so if we can jump the gun
and have that happen at our next meeting
that'll be great so I'll talk to you
more about that does anybody object to
that by the way I mean I think that's
something we should do just to keep the
process going
here um so okay last meeting oh
de just a question that on that um the
scope of the ser services that are to be
provided you you briefly alluded to them
but could you take them off uh what are
what are we expecting from this group
and um specifically I'm wondering about
uh whether they're going to tell us
anything about what other states are
doing on problem gambling yeah you know
we um you other thing I thought you know
we're going to get copies of the
spectrum proposal to everybody okay um I
mean it's in here but the main thing is
what I just said you know we want an
outside person to come in and Survey the
industry with that knowledge to come in
and tell us you know that U especially
on the historic racing machines what did
the allocation really between the the
facilities and the state because you can
look at the state that the state's
giving some of their money to the Char
you know it's like or all three really
but so and then the other thing is
oversight you know you know how do we
compare given that we have all these big
players coming in now what's how do we
look in terms of our oversight do we
need more resource do we need more audit
for instance do we need more you know
things like that um and is there
something that we're not doing that we
should be doing uh to to um keep this
type
now you know I just spoke to the
Assistant Attorney General before the
meeting uh he he mentioned that you know
maybe it's was a good idea to have maybe
Maine or Massachusetts and we come in we
may do that uh from a a regulation
standpoint uh to talk about and he said
this morning maybe Massachusetts
probably the better one to have come in
um and um and hear from them um uh and
we may do that but again to me the
real the real thing is to get the
consult
going so that we have facts that we can
work with them on back and forth as to
what we want to do in those areas so yes
Charlie we're doing a separate proposal
aren't we for problem gaming because
these though if I remember right the
proposal we sent out for this one was
Regulatory and Regulatory and and you
know Fe structure kind of laws um and I
thought we're doing a separate one for
problem G we would yeah yeah
so and also the scope also includes um
sort of the natural Marketplace for New
Hampshire as well the Spectrum that's
the third component for this right and
we do have money given that the proposal
came in at about about 880,000
uh 778 but then there travel on top of
that uh and we have what one well well
in that bucket we have 125 for
Consultants right so there there's and I
would imagine that that can the
U the problem gaming one wouldn't be as
expensive but I don't know I wouldn't
think so yeah I wouldn't think so you
want to do an RFP for uh responsible
gambling consultant Services it would be
right much
less so then if we're going to do that
we should
um it sounds like then we should start
that process to to find a
consultant um okay so can we do do we
have names of
maybe matter of fact our next agenda
item is to have Ed Albert who's really
involved in the in problem gaming in our
state um in that regard it's probably
not unreasonable to sort of send an
email or a request to the National
Council on problem gambling because they
would have the most upto-date national
statistics I think okay all right so we
okay so we'll we'll get that moving um
and give everybody an update on that in
that regard they might even do it for
sort of a donation
essentially again I I I also think this
is the meat and potatoes right this is
the the what the really heavy heavy lift
is the laws and regulations as they
compare to other states it's problem
gaming is much easier lift when you look
at statistical information and that kind
of stuff so I think again I know there
are several places like Miami University
of Ohio has a whole college division
dedicated nothing but problem gaming and
researching problem gaming so there are
people out there that have speci just in
that field right okay well that's good
so all right I'm glad glad that came up
and um we'll move that
forward uh talking about problem gaming
um last meeting we had someone who was
really under your tutelage right under
your your stff no no your stff your
staff yeah was in our head of marketing
yes right also appointed to the council
right and so we have somebody from uh
from the that's really in the trenches
let's say really looking at this issue
um and that's Ed Talbert we finally
tracked him down and here he is in
loving color so Ed the floor is yours um
he did give us a handout about his
organization and I put on everybody's
desk here
somewhere floor is
yours uh can you can you uh push the
button and bring the M Clos do you
please thank you chairman The Reason by
the way by the way I should say two
things uh we have our young lady at at
the end of the table here because she's
hard a hearing we're allowing her to sit
there so no one she's down in the
commission and uh um and these these
meetings are being recorded they're
being broadcast just so you know okay
and then they're they're out there on
YouTube okay anyway go through it thank
you and thank you for the opportunity to
present today it's appropriate that I'm
here today because March is problem
gambling Awareness Month celebrated
across the country and we have many
activities to go along with that I
provided a brochure from the New
Hampshire Council the only thing I'd
like to address on the brochure is the
mission of the council it's a 501c3
organizations it's a private nonprofit
agency created to address the social
financial and emotional cost of problem
gambling the council provides
information education advocacy for
Prevention Services and referrals to
treatment for those Afflicted their
loved ones and the general community and
the contact information our website
that's all included on the
brochure I told uh the chairman that I
had prepared something that I like to
read Because at 81 years old I tend to
sometimes get off track or say more than
I should and I want to be cognizant of
your agenda so if you'll bear with me
I'll be very glad to answer any
questions you may have my name is Ed
tala and they currently serve as the
co-director of the New Hampshire Council
on problem gambling along with Angela
Bergen of Bo I'm an 81 year old resident
of Madison retired from a 20-year
Corrections office as an
administrator and resigned as Chief of
Staff when Massachusetts offered an
extra five years of service I took
advantage of that opportunity I went to
work for radare Hospital a premier
substance abuse facility out of wara
Massachusetts that involved getting
people into detox and then transitioning
from detox into outpatient
services my duties um I've owned a home
in Madison New Hampshire since 1990 it
was primarily a vacation home uh for use
of family friends and occasionally a
rental I sold that house in 2009 and
bought a newer one uh closer to the
water uh in the same development and
declared it to be my retirement home and
changed my residency to New Hampshire on
most Monday evenings I introduced myself
as Ed T compulsive gambling with
gratitude for 46 years since my last B
my gambling addiction took just about
everything for me other than the promise
that there's a chance to recover and
develop a better way of life I was an
incorporated incorporator a board member
and a trainer for the massachusett
Council on compulsive gambling my work
with Tom Cummings the founder of the
council and Kathy scandin it's longtime
executive director provided a wonderful
background uh for me in developing
relationships to further identify
address and treat problem gambling I was
in the first group of individuals
certified by Massachusetts Council and
Mass Department of Public Health as
problem gambling specialist I contracted
with agencies who primarily were
providing substance views to deal with
clients who also had a gambling issue in
2013 I was spending more time in New
Hampshire and planning to change my
residency but wanted to get involved in
expanding gambling services in New
Hampshire and made that known to Kathy
scan I learned that the New Hampshire
Council on problem gambling had been
Incorporated in
1996 by an individual also directing the
Vermont Council on problem gam in 2010
the National Council recommended that
each state be operated
independently we got a small group of
volunteers to get together the first
flow roadblock we ran into was an annual
report had not been filed with the
internal revenue for three years and
under the Patriot Act that eliminated
the 5013 status after an 18month battle
with the assistance of Senator Shaheen
aot and Governor Hassen it was restored
to its
501c3 at my initial meeting with the New
Hampshire lottery director Charlie
McIntyre he stated that it was a social
obligation of those providing G
legalized gambling to address problem
gim direct director McIntyre backed
those words by arranging for donations
totaling
$75,000 over three years in in kind
services including website development
and hosting brochure stationary and
creation printing as well as use of
office SP for board meetings and
assigning his director of marketing Mora
mccan to work with us the 2017
legislation to authorize Kino included
1% of the proceeds be directed to
problem gambling services and
administered by the Department of Health
and Human Services we were the sole
responder to a d Department of Health
and Human Services request for
information for comprehensive Services
recommended for the state nothing of a
materials materialized from that New
Hampshire Council had established
Statewide helpline an office at new
Futures Fair Street location we were
presenting at recovery centers and
Recovery coachies providing information
for train in trainings for Community
State agencies as well as charal gaming
providers the council was successful in
s securing a grant the New Hampshire
Char Foundation to further expand our
help line we also coordinated with 211
New Hampshire to respond to individuals
seeking treatment for problem G the 2019
legislation authorized Sports gambling
created the council for responsible
gambling next to representative in
it provides $250,000 annually to address
problem gambling by way of contracts
developed by and dispersed by the
responsible gambling Council we the New
Hampshire Council on problem gambling
were rewarded the original contract at
$100,000 a year for fiscal years 21 22
and
23 on the day that contract was awarded
we had a bank balance of
$172 and with three months in Aras with
the new futures for our
rent and needless to say to contract was
welcome relief we moved with the Futures
to the present location 100 North Main
Street across the street signed a shared
services agreement with them to
provideed an office phone internet
advocacy and financial help including
bookkeeping payroll Etc unfortunately Co
hit and our personal appearances were
hampered by the pandemic yet Services
continued such as the helpline via Zoom
FaceTime and phone recovery support
especially in conjunction with gam
Anonymous improved greatly Manchester
meeting on Tuesday night became the
first hybrid meeting in the area where
the meeting was held in person at New
Hampshire at
um recovery New Hampshire on Wilson
Street in person as well as on Zoom we
have been proud to be part of that
transition and that meeting typically
runs 10 to 12 people inhouse and
approximately 20 people online every
week an option to extend our contract
for another year was initiated in April
of 2023 we were asked to provide an
outline of services that we would
provide under that
contract that was done but it was not
accepted the responsible cam League
council did inform us that they were
hoping to secure an original amount for
$250,000 in the fiscal year 24 budget
but wouldn't that would be
successful the Council on new the New
Hampshire Council on problem gaming made
a decision to pass on that $100,000
renewal for three factors one a need to
renew our contract with new Futures
including office space equipment and
financial
services having worked in the public
sector in Massachusetts I know what it
was like to never have a budget ready at
the start of the year but in the Private
Industry I wasn't ready to sign a
contract that would commit the council
to a lot more money that we could
actually afford we worked with them to
parir it down cut back the services and
developed the budget that we felt we
could handle with what we had and based
on what we could see foresee as income
coming in like contributions from
DraftKings $15,000 each year for a
three-year period and our participation
in charal gaming which now is has been
around
$30,000 the council was informed by one
of the commissions that they were
seeking 250 ,000 and would be hiring
somebody with expertise in
self-exclusion and let me read from the
email regarding our response to
voluntary self-exclusion this is tricky
because we've discussed creating a
full-time position gambling responsible
gambling position at the lottery if that
position is created that person would be
doing a lot of the work required for to
set up a centralized bu voluntary
self-exclusion process but it is
dependent on getting the New Hampshire
Council respons Cil gam funded restored
and that's still an open question so the
bottom line is if the council got the
250,000 they were going in a separate
Direction with this hired person in that
if the
100,000 uh were the the budget figure
then it would fall back on us which we
felt we really couldn't handle something
to that
extent so we made the decision to pass
on that that does not mean that we not
participate in any opportunity to bid on
what we think we can do uh but that and
the third reason I applaud the industry
for all the notice they take responsible
gambling that's not our clientele uh our
clientele are not going back to gambling
we don't teach people that you can
gamble safely again most of the people
we encounter have crossed the line and I
have to tell you from personal
experience in 46 years of attending
thousands and thousands of Gamblers
Anonymous meeting and talking to
thousands of problem gamblers I have
never heard a person who relapsed come
back in and say it wasn't as bad this
time it's a progressive disease it's
never going to get better you can arrest
it but you're not going to cure it so
that me was the basis for our decision
uh not to seek funing this year I'd like
to talk a little bit about the helpl
line and then talk about what I see is
the most critical need in that is
voluntary self-exclusion uh I have
figures on the helpline calls over the
last three years uh and the total number
of calls uh that we received in uh
2021 was approximately 200 I'm not sure
some of the calls from December from the
previous year that but it was around 200
out of that we identified 65 people as
problem Gams in
2022 the calls went up to
227 57 were identified as problem
gamers in 2023 306 calls were received
78 were from problemin Gams and so far
this year we've received 72 calls and 13
of them were from Pro regarding or
designated as persons with a problem
with
gambling we get many more calls a lot of
the calls as you probably can imagine
are from loved ones of The Gambler and
not most gamblers don't pick up the
phone and say hey I've got a problem
they're referred by somebody else we
follow up with the contacts when we do
get one we follow up with them we get
calls from the media we get calls from
we get a call from a representative
regularly who wants to know why we can't
be like game sense in Massachusetts and
have people station in each one of the
casinos well if you got a $3.6 million
budget like the mass Council and
compulsive family you can afford to do
that but on $100,000 we can't commit to
something like that I think it's a great
program and a great idea but we can't do
that um we also get calls from groups to
do presentations on that so there are a
lot of other calls that come in not the
six calls is the six calls actually
represent a figure of what we feel is
accurate information for the number of
PR gamblers who reach our help line I
just want to add one more figure to that
I said there were about 35 people who
normally attend the gamble Anonymous
meeting on Tuesday night in
Manchester one quarter of those have
come through the uh New Hampshire
council help line there are two people
that are in that meeting now one who has
celebrated two years in recovery another
one approaching uh one year later this
month with the help of Mora McAn in the
New Hampshire lottery self-excluded
through the iot and that stuff and then
doing doing very very well um so it's
great to have that option and it calls
out the need for that I re regarding
voluntary self-exclusion I'm so glad the
commission is interested in addressing
that because I certainly believe a
centralized system is essential in the
state two weeks ago I got a call from
Mrs locken from G2 gaming would call the
New Hampshire Lottery and they referred
here to me and I guess they oversee
their company overseas ocean gaming and
they wanted to know if the people who
had self-excluded at their Casino were
registered in our database well a we
don't have a database uh positively the
state should have one and I told her she
was astonished she smoke states do I I
understand we're trying to get something
like that
developed uh hopefully in the future
that's and we'll be very happy to work
with one one of the things that I don't
understand and I'm sure you'll all agree
with this you take a person who admits
to having a gambling problem and tell
him he has to go to each and every one
of these places to self-exclude you're
putting him in the gambling situation
itself uh and you hope that that's
satisfactory uh and they're not provided
with any treatment information uh
there's only three gambl and honorous
meetings in Hampshire presently one in
um do on Monday night one in the
Manchester meting on Tuesday night uh
and a third one in Hamstead on uh
Thursday night um that those are the
resources we have we have some councils
for training now since we've gone and I
want to say independent but since we
passed an State funding some of the
things that we have done is the website
had been developed by um title media on
the the New Hampshire lottery we've gone
independent we created our road website
uh we can make changes on the flight uh
my co-director was an expert in
computers and all that stuff I'm not she
makes the changes she handles all the um
show social media things so we have our
own website now um that has prompted a
lot of donations as well um we have you
know PayPal on there so people can Don
donate to um finally uh we have created
what's probably the first I know in the
region is an intensive outpatient um
program developed with one of our Bor
them Sister Mary Joseph uh on River
works for riverend Behavioral Health
which will provide intensive outpatient
services to people with a gambling
problem we've never had such a group
they're off for substance abuse and
that's very very effective so a person
early in recovery would go to a group
like that we also have developed the
Pilot Course for clinicians peer
Specialists and that will which we will
be offering in May um we're going to do
that free of charge for the first pilot
program and then after that we'll be
charging we're working with New
Hampshire alcohol and drug council's
associate to provide that training uh
and finally uh next week Tuesday is um
National screening day for problem
gambling uh we will be doing a public
screening with all clients who attend
River Bend's Church behavioral health
program next week they'll all be
screened for the presence of gambling we
provide that information to um hav
university the division of addiction
where they coordinate all that and
finally we'll be addressing on the same
day on Tuesday a grou group of guidance
councils from schools in New Hampshire
regarding problem gambling especially
with adolescence tonight I thank you
very much for your attention and I
welcome any questions you may have let
me start so you get you get ,000 from
the state correct for three years for
three years that ended okay and that
ended and the rest is you fundraise
sounds like the rest we have in what we
had left in the bank balance wasn't an
awful lot we're projecting $30,000 in
revenue from jwood gaming we're
projecting $155,000 in revenue from uh
DraftKings as the third year of their
installment to every Council in the
United States gets $15,000 a year threee
period from traffing so that was when
they get the NFL contract so last
meeting we had an interesting discussion
about breakage and part of the statute
when the historic racing machines came
in breakage was supposed to go to this
fund this problem gambling fund um um we
found out that one of the vendors isn't
contributing because they don't have
that in their software but let's just
say the other two are contributing so
this money is going somewhere is what is
the leg is it that the legislature has
not appropriated you any money because
can you
please so when you identify a revenue
Source you also have to identify um the
budget amount and so the budget amount
is $250,000 for this fiscal year and the
source is breakage last year it was
100,000 and Source was breakage it
exceeded last year's amount it's not
quite as much this year as the 200,000
but it doesn't matter we still will
contribute the amount that you folks
dictated in the budget so it's one of
the so then why so then who spends this
money so right now there's been no
expenditure this year that I'm aware of
from that
funds the the amount of the $3,000 is
just I don't think it's been spent all
right well so it's just sitting there
yeah because the legislature in the
budget process hasn't appropriated any
money to nope Money's been appropriated
and it's in the budget it's just the
there's been no expenditure which is is
um Ed suggested I think four three years
ago when it was Health and Human
Services or four I think there was
800,000 in the account that was not
expended at the end of the year if it's
not expended it literally just rolls
into our transfer amount for the for the
transfer the education trust fund right
because as unex because our well look
back at a second by the terms of the
Constitution the lottery revenues are
revenues minus expenses equals transfer
to education trust fund and the way this
this is set up the responsible gambling
is an expense of the lottery and if
there's no expenditure than it's
literary rolls as as a as a transfer
right so yeah Senator so my question is
it sounds like you don't have a contract
with the lottery so is it just a matter
of we need a contract executed in order
to expend those funds and we've let the
contract lapse and you already have the
statutory Authority correct so it so the
contract is only administered by us it's
not we're by Design as you could imagine
I'm not in charge of responsible
building in the state that would be very
much a conflict with my job and so
there's a separate uh Council that's
supposed to manage that function and so
at this point so follow so again I'm
going trying to get pragmatically where
we're stuck at where the where theak
where the problem is right where the
breakage is
but um the breaket broken and so right
now we have stats to authority to have
that allow to pay them to continue to
service problem gambling in the state we
just don't have a executed contract from
them to whether it's DS so the
commission on problem gaming who would
authorize the contract correct and
there's money in the account to do that
yeah well it's not money in the account
it's literally just a budget it's a line
item for us but yes so Ed I think G
March quarters you know we need to work
on getting the contract to the
commission so they get help fund your
our some of our problem gaming well is
there anybody I'm going to there's one
more question over here I know but is
there anybody else it sounds like you
are the group that is doing something in
this front in this state with a lot of
volunteers
yeah is there anybody else that you know
of that's doing what you folks are doing
I do not know of anybody else who in the
state that's doing it I mean other
states have conss and they do work and
all that um we are two part-time people
uh Dr Bergen also works for riverband in
conquer hospital um I work part-time we
each uh theot our talents and our
services I do most of the administrative
recovery support and the helpline work I
handle a helpline almost exclusively I
was just on ruber for a week and Dr
Bergen took it for uh the week and Ruba
cost me Co I hadn't I had dodged Co for
three years I came back and get that but
Dr Bergen handle that we also have
somebody in the recovery program if I
need somebody to take place on the
helpline they'll handle that call right
but other than that all the heline calls
go through thank you well you have a
question over here and
then yeah I want to thank Mr taler for
his testimony it was very good if if
it'd be possible here to have your
prepared remarks given over to our to
our secretary and sent out to all the
members here emailed yep we'll make that
happen yes can you get us a
Cy thank you
representative I'm I'm just wondering
what whether this has to be looked at
through the RFP process I was gonna that
was my next question as well that's why
I was asking others out
there
um I would imagine it has to be Charlie
I'm looking at
you it does yeah it has to be anytime
it's a state contract has to be a bid
process
so another question I know there are
several um National organizations that
handle it for a lot of States um and
they're usually the ones who respond to
the rfbs as well so all right
thanks Senator thank
you first of all thank you very much for
your testimony appreciate it very much
the
15,000 that was allocated because of the
the what the
NFL because of 15,000 yes DraftKings yes
now how how was that a who receives it
and how was it received each Council in
the United States state Council in the
United States gets that gets $115,000
from
DraftKings so there's no State
involvement in that at all go goes
directly into your account deposit in
your account you're giving the account
information actually it was the last two
years we got it in January we haven't
got it yet so I don't know whether Draft
Kings isn't a little tight right now I
can't imagine that but uh but that
that's due uh but they give each Council
in the United States
$15,000 is that just for three years the
contract was for three years and this is
the third year of the contract they
haven't said anything about going any
further they um sent out a survey every
year what have you done with the money
what you know what suggestions do you
have and that we've responded to that
all the
time that that's like the uh you know I
heard at the last meeting that 211 New
Hampshire uh was somehow going to take
over the help line that we with new
two11 New Hampshire since 2015 that they
have all our contact information
somebody calls with a problem gambling
and that uh they refer to us uh if I
could just make one suggestion regarding
the
250,000 um I really think that kind of
money would be well spent if you could
develop a voluntary self-exclusion that
would cover the entire State we we're
not that PE those people we're not going
to create a database and maintain a
database and that it's going to be
somebody else and that's what I said and
I sent a separate note to Charlie that
we're doing the things that we know we
can do physically and financially and um
Vol especially you as a volunteers uh
we're not you know we're not mass
counselors we don't have a budget of
$3.6 million in addition they got the
office of problem gambling services that
has spent $7.8 million on uh prevention
and $1.9 million on treatment in the
last 10 years and I think that what was
that called Public Health Trust Fund or
something that they all had to pay into
yeah it's like some
years yeah yeah I mean huge sums of
money so when you say use the words
state recognized who recognized you you
know what I mean you said you you were
state
recognized by DraftKings I mean but who
who what what makes you the state
recognized to me that means something we
had the existing Council and problem G
we it's because we had a council and
we're functioning as a council we got
that money right all right well
representative Ames goes first and
then I first want to say thank you for
being here and I think back to my first
meeting you when I was working on the
gaming commission at that time in 2013
or 12 or somewhere around then and uh
you were doing the good work that you're
doing now then and it obviously carried
on with it so many thanks for you
impressed me so much then because I
couldn't believe a representative was
down in Massachusetts attending as many
functions regarding problem gaming I say
talk about doing your homework so thank
you very much thank you um I think a big
part of the I think there's a big
problem here that's structural that we
need to address um right now we have a I
believe it's titled Council for
responsible gaming do I have that right
yeah you just pulled it up how about
that Council responsible G it's RSA
338b so we so that's that's a
statutory uh state established Council
and the members I believe are appointed
by the governor and council is that what
it is right um and um and that's where
the money that's that's the result of
breakage or whatever else that comes out
of the state's treasury is uh going and
then for allocation out um there are
structural problems one Charlie alluded
to that it
um it's independent is compromised and
Charlie's put in a difficult position
having it essentially in his office um
and we need to think about how that
might be restructured I've talked um on
previous occasions with Charlie about
positioning at uh over at uh uh Health
and Human Services and maybe that would
make sense uh but we never really got to
the point of being confident enough to
push that so we need to think that
through and um I think we'll be helped
it's very helpful to have the input from
Mr talet that we've gotten today but
also I'd love to hear from massachusett
which is sort of at the other end of the
spectrum and and they've had as part of
their big gambling bill when they jumped
into BigTime gambling they had a
comprehensive Commission and allocated a
stream of money that's going into
respons responsible G gambling
automatically as as gambling proceeds so
there's a lot to learn I think from
their experience that goes into both
research as well as uh treatment and
prevention um and so uh we've got our
work to do and I hope we'll be able to
um both got a good handle on what the
world that we living in has to offer
here in New Hampshire and then what we
might be able to do in the last meeting
I think we talked about this Council but
it sounded like it's not a very active
Council yeah right do I have that
correct Senator delandre do you have you
end up before yeah just to finish up I I
think represent AES is correct we got we
have there's a council but it's it's
it's a known entity in essence really
because you don't have much anybody
that's number one and and number two you
haven't got any people how how the hell
do you do it without anybody without any
people and and we gotta we we've talked
about it but uh we we Haven it we have
it delivered and and I think two things
ought to be made clear to the
public in Most states you have to be 21
to go into a casino in New Hampshire you
have to be 18
huge
differential right there and and that's
that's something that we ought to look
at because my in involvement in this
game has been for a long period of time
and what what supposedly is happening
across the country is younger people are
becoming involved particularly at as
sports betting has been has been opened
up and the phone the sports betting and
the fact that we're 18 because I I I
believe in in our surrounding states
it's 21 am I correct are you
correct I don't know whether you saw it
but there was recently a story in the
Boston Globe where the director of the
Massachusetts Council on compul gambling
noticed that her son had $50 withdrawals
coming out regularly out of the bank 18
years old he was involved with three
other guys and they were betting Sports
in New
Hampshire and this is the sign of the
person directing the mass Council so
thank you Mr
okay so it sounds like we have some work
to do here on this one
um suggested next
step I to that point fundamentally it's
an operational issue not really a
a uh we all agree that we should fix
this issue the problem is we've
allocated enough money to look at the
problem but fix the problem and
technology is great in the sense of you
know in both of the bills we drafted one
for the internet one for sports betting
we mandated voluntary self exclusion as
well as limits you can set your own
limits um and also the technology behind
DraftKings and our Lottery platform is
if you call our call center and you use
words that are troubling we actually
disable your account so those type of
programs are great the problem is I it's
where people are physically in locations
we can't do stuff like that so we have
to do the fundamental things of at each
location have folks available to talk to
people if they have a problem because I
think Mr tala would agree with me that
it's when an individual identifies thems
as a problem that's the time to approach
them it's it's not a call from a family
member because the Burse is probably not
ready yet um and so it's going to stand
up sort of a an agency on its own either
reporting Health Human Services or
I'd rather not say this but if it has to
be us it has to be us and have some
operational people stand up a program
that's in every location as part of a
mandatory self- exclusion program that
the operators have to absorb and um
permit now I was going to digress a
little bit I'm G look at the two folks
from um the industry
so I know in the historic racing Bill we
had something to do with uh um problem
gambling but it was um having a plan to
identify problem gamblers if I recall
yeah I can answer that if you want sure
yeah there is a plan um uh it is
submitted to us and then our agency
refuses it Audits and and confirms that
it's occurring and every building has
cleared that audit process okay so I'm
going to look at the the facilities and
ask uh it's nice to have a plan but do
do have you referred any any problem
gamblers I guess is what I'm getting at
identified and and
referred um I don't have the exact
counts off the top of my head um but I
know we have a proactive problem gaming
plan um we have a volunteer self-
exclusions 25 or lifetime but again it's
only our properties because there's no
link database right there's no right um
and we put every um employee through uh
problem gaming training when they start
to make sure they could recognize and
proactively approach and like your
dealers and so forth can identify every
everyone food and beverage to across the
board how about your facility is that
similar our facility is very similar we
have a very similar plan and I think our
biggest hurdle is just catching them at
the door because we can't scan those IDs
and so it's you have to recognize them
catch their name as they come in so I'd
say that's our biggest hurdle but we do
track them once they use the rewards
card we can go over and say you self-
excluded you know
right okay
look the watch okay we we got to move
forward now very great thank you uh
you've really spawn a lot of thought
here that's um we're goingon to be
talking to you more over time as oh
that's question yes
yes Mr tal thank you again for your
testimony I'm uh Mark Delano and
assistant an attorney general department
of justice uh maybe you know or perhaps
some of the industry folks on the on the
commission may know uh do the uh
substance abuse uh treatment facilities
or Services here in New Hampshire or
maybe in other states of New England
offer programs around problem gaming uh
and if so does anyone know whether or
not that's covered by medical
insurance very true um most substance
abuse facilities uh problem gamblers
most problem gamblers or 76% of problem
gamblers also have a substance use
disarm um so it's comorbidity is a big
big problem um they're very similar in
their treatment um however slight
differences for example you wouldn't
smoke another joint or drink another
beer and figure that's going to solve
all your problems the gaml thinks the
next bet he makes is going to take every
care of everything everybody will love
him and of course that doesn't happen so
he spiral down or if he does win that
just reinforces the fact that keep
gambling uh so the treatment is a little
bit different uh any substance of use
clinician could see a client billing is
what is difficult some will cover it
it's recognized under dsm5 now as a
disease um the health care model is in
place uh but it's usually tracked under
behavioral help I know when I was
providing in massach that was a special
behavioral health code that would signal
the M the money was coming because we
gambl disorder U but a lot of private
insurance is aren't covering it
yet I do have one more question you had
mentioned problem gamblers it's
Anonymous I don't know if that's the
exact title so is it your organization
that runs those meetings or are there
other anonymous groups out there all
those organizations are run
independently each group is independent
okay but there are others around the
state yes okay smart recovery is another
one but the three gamblers and honorous
meetings are DOA Hamstead and Manchester
okay all right thank you thank you very
much for your time and uh committee uh
commission members we we got we've got
to think about what we want to do next
with this issue but we're got to move
forward on the agenda here so uh we have
three more guests now coming um Can
someone
uh we we got to pull one more chair up
here so if uh we're gonna we're going to
talk about what one more thing on the
agenda hang on one more thing Charlie
for Charlie first
sorry uh Charlie's already designed and
sent out uh charal gaming survey uh
we're GNA get the survey form emailed to
us uh sometime hopefully today it's
pretty extensive I I just I just seen it
for my first time and Charlie why don't
you just update us yeah so as I
described earlier that we were going to
do a survey of the childwood gambling um
area and we're working with UNH uh that
went
out eight days ago 10 days ago and um
could be the the link will be uh over
this week of the 800 Charities I think
so far we have at least as of last
Wednesday we had 260 responses so I
would anticipate more than 300 responses
total which obviously n equals 300 is a
valid survey sample size um the the
questions include both you know
percentage click boxes like there's four
choices choose one as well as open-ended
questions where they can respond with a
word or two so um it was like I said it
was drafted with the help of unh Andy
Smith and I'll forward you the survey
when I get back to my office I didn't
have time this morning to print 20
copies so I didn't and and his team and
his team is going to reduce the data for
us too yeah well exactly yeah yeah and
then he will his team will come here
present the results okay sounds good any
questions on that I I thought that was a
little faster than going out to bid and
a contract and because we have a
research budget and obviously Char
gambling is part of our operation so
okay thank you um well I was one of the
individuals who Reed the survey uh easy
to go through well presented and I think
a great a great list of questions and
the stuff so that U it was it was
pleasant to fill out basically here to
get to get through yeah it was an email
from me and I probably got 150 responses
so I was was had a busy email day so
it's good to hear it wasn't over
taxing so okay well thanks thanks
Charlie for the update on that and
thanks for comments so uh so we've
invited uh three different charities
from different regions of the state and
of different size
facilities uh we have uh one to three of
you come up we have Don morsy from Lakes
Region Casino which is he representing
leaders leadership Lakes Region we have
Mike
baderan uh from who who whose days are
at lucky moose and he's represents the
the locky the Lions Club and then Larry
c caman u from Angel Flight and he's at
the Brooke so can all three of you come
up and pull one more chair up thank you
uh what happened to our friend who was
Don left the room for just a minute yeah
he'll be back so why don't we start with
the the two of you what they what
they're going to do is each going to
give a a brief uh description of their
their Charities and and this General
comments about the relationship with
their facilities and then uh then we'll
open up to questions so we'll start here
my name is Mike bagin you can move the
microphone Clos to yourself just go
slide it over you can slide it over y my
name is Mike bagin and I'd like to
represent two different charities
tonight because we're in Lucky moves
with both of them first one is the exit
are Lance club which covers six towns in
the on the Sea Coast same as our school
system and we've been at the lucky Mo
now for a couple years and the process
has been extremely easy and without
without the money that we raised from
them we could not do the programs that
we do
um we've been able in our area add on to
what we
do this last couple years we've added on
fuel assistance for those in need we've
been going to the schools and finding
out single moms and and we're able to
help 22 different charities 22 different
families last two years on Heating and
and uh I think that made a big
difference we support food Charities uh
it goes on and on ey
glasses um different surgeries and
fundraising is getting harder all the
time out here and this this has just
made life so much easier and and the
lucky mov alone there's over 17 Lions
organizations and I know this some down
at the brook also and talking to them
it's just it's made an incredible
difference in the communities that we
that we take care of the other group
that I represent is the New Hampshire
police fire and EMS Foundation we're
501c3 that was
organized how about I think 06
um that is an organization that helps
First Responders in time of need not
mostly work rated uh sometimes if they
run out of work as comp is one thing but
uh we help with like right now we're
doing a pro helping a family uh out
firefighter out of Milford he has a set
of three-year-old twins one of them just
came down with a very acute case of
Leukemia and is going undergoing 32
treatments down in Boston and he's
unable to work and and without it is
without pay we have taken up that
project and for the next several months
we'll be paying a minimum of $1,500 to
help keep that family afloat it's that
type of thing that we do a lot of cancer
problems uh and the longer the
foundation's been around the bigger the
need we do do other fun fundraises but
at this time it see I like to say that
everybody out there is chasing the same
dollar with businesses and there's only
so much they can do uh the paper prod
process the state has put together has
helped us
tremendously uh and before this last
couple years I think my wife has been
fingerprinted more times than anybody in
the state with the two organizations
it's it's streamlined it's easy the
people at the lucky Mose are very easy
to deal with and basically at this point
I don't know what would what we would do
without the help that the state helped
us with I think it was a wonderful idea
to partnership with the Charities on the
state's part portion thank you for this
what we're going to do is let all three
speak first and then we're gonna ask
questions so they can all answer the
same
question okay we got um hi Larry cam
Larry right I'm gu we go next right
P right what hi Larry camelon I'm a
Catholic priest and I'm the founder of
Angel Flight uh both New Hampshire and
New England and Mr McIntyre we loved
your survey uh we filled it out returned
it the same day we got it so we should
be one of the first ones that you
received it you know it's an absolute
honor and a privilege to be here with
you today and I'm so glad you invited us
all to to speak of charitable gaming and
the profound effects uh we were able to
provide for the grant Staters here uh I
establish Angel 5 New England in
1996 we're a nonprofit 501c3
organization and we provide unlimited
free flights to medically stable
ambulatory people needing to access
Access Medical Care we were doing a
fundraiser at Bretton Woods uh where we
bought a condo back in
1994 and in 1995 we were doing a ski
event a fundraiser there and a lot of
the local people who live there
full-time you know want to participate
in it and support
it and as we were doing that as they
were going around you know trying to get
auction items from the local businesses
and Littleton and Berlin and gor and
everything we suddenly realized the
profound F profound need in the North
country you know for access to medical
care and we we knew there was one there
but a lot of our volunteers said you
know we need to start a full-time
program you know a marketing Angel
Flight doing community outreach
throughout the entire State and we found
people especially in the North Country
felt much more comfortable it was Angel
FL New Hampshire so we incorp par the
angel FL of New Hampshire back in
2006 and in 201 um 12 well we start a
relationship with SEO funding which was
the original poker room as many of you
probably remember and through uh 2012
through
2019 uh we received $1
15,879 from them and then when they
transition to the Brooke uh from 2021
through 2024 we received over
$329,000 so in total we received as of
two weeks ago
$480,500
and the brook has been an absolutely
incredible generous tremendous partner
to us they are such wonderful people
I've known lri since she was at the
poker room and they are thrilled that
the partnership ship that you
allow allows people to access health
care now we have over 450 volunteer
Pilots so whatever pilot flies the
flight he or she picks up the entire
cost of their own pocket we also have
two major airline Partners JetBlue and
Cape Air and they give us unlimited
positive space seats on their flights
for our patients when need the weather
or distance precludes us flying in
little airplanes now our planes like
four to eight seed planes you know and
we uh we' flown out of we and we still
do of course fly out 13 Hampshire
airports uh Manchester of course peas
conquet nashar Mount Washington Valley
and Whitefield Lebanon Kean lonia Berlin
uh clemont uh Sky Haven and Hampton and
we have FL what's remarkable when we
were doing these statistics to present
to you today that people coming from 105
New Hampshire
communities and our very very F I'd like
to tell you a few stories about our
patients and our very first two patients
was Lieutenant Commander Dave Hill he
was in the US Coast guide he was based
at peas and his wife took the year and a
half old son down to Delaware to visit
her
parents and while they were in Delaware
the baby had a m massive seizure and was
admitted to the ICU while she took their
only car so he called an 800 number and
heard about
us and we flew him on May 31st a very
very first patient you know from peas
down to Delaware the second patient was
in New Hampshire resident it was
eight-year-old Patrick carac out of
Manchester and Patrick had had diagnosed
with a Glo blast J brain tumor
and he was operated at the Elliott
hospital and he did very well initially
and then it came back about a year and a
half later and they referred him to Dana
Faber and the brigam he went there for
treatment and then they said well
there's nothing more we can do you know
but there's a new protocol a new
clinical trial at NIH in say to Maryland
well at this time his mother Sharon
called us Patrick was only eight
and they had exhausted the family funds
you know between co-pays and deductibles
and mom and dad being out of work and
this is what happens with patients we
see that we
fly so we flew Patrick eight times in a
clinical trial to Bethesda Maryland you
know
unfortunately that clinical trial did
not prove ous and and Patrick did pass a
few months later but we have been able
to to fly as I said you know people from
106 communities thousands and thousands
of Grant Staters you know to uh 93
medical centers throughout the United
States and in my handout I gave you on
the fact sheet you know just a sample of
some of those medical centers from
Memorial slone catering Children's
Research Hospital in Colorado Duke
University Cleveland Clinic the Mayo
Clinic Kennedy ker Institute in
Baltimore Maryland plus all the Boston
hospitals and I we featured um little
Adam on the front
cover Adam a small child from berkline
and he suffers from uh oi osteogenesis
in perfecta it's a very very rare
disease that's incurable and we fly him
to the ker Center uh in Baltimore uh
currently um I I I included this picture
one of our Pilots took of um uh Morgan
she's 33 years old and she lives in
London dery and she has a brain tumor
and we're flying her daily to uh bring
him a Women's Hospital in Boston but she
has to be there at a very very certain
time exact time for her treatment and so
with weather issues this winter and
freezing levels and even though the lack
of know we've had an issue with snow
it's easier for her if we buy her an
Uber so we'll purchase an Uber ticket
and put her from London uh I think it's
to Manchester and then we put her on
conquer bus lines down to Boston so
whether someone needs a flight or they
need an an Uber lift uh to get to a
larger airport or if for some reason uh
they can't fly because of medical
reasons you know recent nervous surgery
or cardiac surgery that's what we'll do
we're also flying a young man Lenny out
of uh Portsmouth to Dana Faba he has a
very rare disease we started flying him
on December 23rd and also Linda we're
flying out of peas to Mount Si Hospital
in uh Manhattan and since
20122 we provided her with 100
flights um there's a great story that I
forgot all about and during my research
I I remembered it and back on December
9th and it's in your booklet
2010 uh there was a patient his name was
Ken from St Louis
Missouri and Kathy from pelum now
Rebecca of St Louis intended to give her
kidney to her fiance Ken at Bond's
Jewish Hospital in St Louis at the same
time while Kathy from henah had planned
on donating her kidney to a
sister-in-law Kathy from pelum at do
with medical Hitchcock Center but
neither were a
match and now they start this
experimental National donor matching
program through
niage and when they put them in the
database they found that the people in
St Louis with a match for the New
Hampshire patient and the New Hampshire
patient was a match for the person in St
Louis but now how are we going to do
this so this was the first in region
paired kidney transplant in history of
the
country so Dr Tika called us and we had
two of our Pilots one in the St Louis
area and one from New Hampshire work
with the hospitals we made sure we had a
good weather window window again because
these are small planes you know and they
decided to meet in
Pittsburgh so both donors the kidneys
were extracted put in coolers one
brought to Lebanon airport and the other
brought to St Louis put them right in
the planes met on a taxi way in
Pittsburgh brought the kidneys back and
successful transplants isn't that
awesome I mean that was incredible it
was the first one ever you know in the
United States so when you look at in
fact we have 80 Pilots for New Hampshire
residents and we fly people from over a
100 communities out of 13 airports to 93
medical centers throughout the United
States the the support we get from the
brook and yall is them through
charitable gaming and the partnership
with New Hampshire nonprofits and the
commission and the casinos has been life
saving for so many people I me it's a
third of our budget a year uh that this
provides us with service it's awesome I
can't thank you enough thank you
Father um we're GNA have questions in a
minute so the only other thing I want to
say about the SE was that the old uh
shoe store that we were Us in it was the
brook was the old shoe store yeah the SE
Coast right yeah I remember as I live on
the Sea Coast I remember driving by
there once before I knew anything about
I was in legator I knew anything about
Char gaming I'm going geez the old true
scor is now have his poker I didn't know
what the hell that was I
know poker I guess that poker what was
the name of Sho store do you remember
was a Dexter was a Dexter
store okay very good thank you sure and
last up is Don Mar Marcy yes good
morning all and thank you for this
opportunity um I don't have a kidney
story like ble Larry but I um thank God
thank God uh we are so very uh pleased
uh I represent two nonprofits in The
Lakes Region uh leadership Lakes Region
which I was a co-founder of in
1996 it's a regional uh leadership
program uh for upand cominging leaders
in our Lakes Region Community uh we are
one of several in the state of New
Hampshire I believe we have the
distinction of being the only
independent prog program non affiliated
with a corporate sponsor or a chamber of
commerce uh in addition to that I also
am the treasurer for uh the stem
education for youth nonprofit using
aviation and Aeros space as a basis and
a focus and we're based at the lonia
airport uh that's called win Arrow so
leadership Lakes Region was my first and
in
2009 I was asked to join and help form a
win Arrow stem education for youth um
this has been a um wonderful benefit the
gaming uh program charity gaming a
wonderful program for us because it
enables us to do additional things that
our budget simply cannot do we're all
volunteers we have no paid employees we
do have an independent contractor whom
we compensate but other than that uh
we're all volunteers on our board um
this enables us the proceeds and and I
should preface this by saying last fall
we received our initial uh benefit for
win Aro from the Lakes Region casino and
this spring we received our initial
benefit from uh the Lakes Region Casino
for leadership Lakes Region so I'm new
to the game but uh based on what we've
had this past several months it's been a
fantastic benefit for us uh it will
enable us for the Youth in the stem
education program to offer scholarships
to disadvantage Youth and to students of
color and to students of under
representation in the aviation and
Aerospace industry uh primarily
females uh and these scholarships will
help them realize a summer camp
environment on focusing on what they
love to do Aviation and
Aerospace uh for leadership Lakes Region
it will help us def defray our expenses
we have an annual class of 25 Stu uh 25
leaders um we meet eight times a year
and we provide the lunches we provide
catering for graduation uh recognition
plaques when they graduate and rent for
facilities when we need it to house our
particular program days and there are
themed program days throughout the year
um education
economy uh the uh history and culture of
the Lakes Region uh lakes and
environmental day uh political issues
day so these are themed events for us
throughout the year and uh the funds
that we' received will help us def Fray
our expenses it's an expensive program
to operate and uh this will help us
immensely um a word if I might about I I
will just uh say what my colleagues at
this table have said our representation
was through Lakes Region casino and
Belmont the general manager there could
not have been more supportive more
helpful and more genuine than
uh you could expect he was terrific I
went and met him for the first time he
walked me through the entire process uh
he told me what I had to do he gave me
forms that I needed to fill out for the
state and just overall he was a
tremendous help and I was very taken
aback uh how sincere and Cooperative he
was since he was going to be giving us
money uh but was a it was a pleasure to
work with Ryan glot and I would like to
commend him in front of you so thank you
very
much I just want to start with the first
question and then uh representative have
next um so let's start with you Larry
because you're you're the newcomer to
this so how how did you find out about
charitable gaming and um how difficult
was it to get dates because there there
are Charities well the way it works now
each each each of the facilities manages
their own Charities that that come to
them and there's no real centralized way
for you know we're all filled up go to
go up to the lakes to have dates that's
something we need to work on on this
commission but just I'm interested
knowing because you're new new to the
game like you said how did you first
find out and how easy was it to get
dates uh I first found out about this
opportunity when an Air Force I'm
retired Air Force and and a retired that
I know in the area who's on our board uh
for wi Arrow mentioned that at the Sea
Coast a uh nonprofit he was associated
with was uh part of this charitable
gambling initiative and I said what what
is that all about and he explained it to
me I picked up the phone and called The
Lakes Region casino and Mr glot said
come in and see me how's 2:00 sound and
there you go and and that was it now I
did however uh try for the leadership
program um someone said go to the bigger
casinos there's more opportunity there
and more opportunity sounded like more
money to me so um I did approach the
brook the lady was very cordial and
pleasant but she had no vacancies and I
approached uh Gate City Casino again
very nice but they had no vacancies so I
went back to the well uh to uh Lakes
Region Casino in Belmont fortunately he
had a vacancy so both of our
organizations are uh tied to the Lakes
Region
Casino are you getting 10 days at each I
am sir yes okay thank
youa you a question
thanes to a large extent your your
question took care of that but I would
say um my my my questions really have to
do with the
expectation both the access to the days
that are assigned to you and you sp
spoken to that if there's any different
experience I'd like to hear it um and
then um there there's talk about best
days and not so good days in other words
some days when people gamble a lot and
can be expected to and some days that
are sort
of uh a day to stay home shall we say um
and uh if there's any information on
that I'd be interested in that I think
we would be interested in it than any
other expectations that the casinos have
of you that you'll
promote um the activities at the brook
or whatever you know um or uh do do
events that might help uh publicize the
uh opportunity to to engage in gambling
at these casinos anything like that I'd
really be interested in getting is that
a question for everybody yes that's a
question for everybody okay hi uh
representative Ames um we um I was very
reluctant at first about going to a
casino I had never been in a casino I
don't gamble I uh we had a convention
one time out in Las Vegas that I went to
and I was very very uncomfortable
walking through the C you know to get to
my room I I you know I just you know
that's not my scene you know um I've
always kind of uh uh equated to you know
the mafia gambling Crooks and stuff like
that so it made me uncomfortable but
what was amazing as you just said the
experience at the brook and going back
to the poker room with lari and the
management there they have the most
wonderful kindest committed people
people and when we filled out our
application and met with them it wasn't
what can Angel flake do for them is what
can they do for Angel Flight and the
citizens of Na Hampshire and I've gone
up there a couple of times and when we
pick up the check once a year or I stop
by to say hello and they give us a tour
at the
casino and their function rooms and
stuff like that and they said if there's
anything ever we can do for you like if
you wanted to hold a fundraising dinner
or something like that you know would
love to help you out but never any quid
proquo uh never any suggestion well you
know get better do an event here or else
uh nothing I I'm Blown Away by the
goodness the genuine goodness of the
people and and the leadership of the
brook you know let me ask you follow up
on that so do you do you get uh are you
10 days all at once or do you did they
break it up five days and five days or 3
days and seven days or it's always been
uh I think since the days of the poker
room yeah it's 10 days all at once okay
yeah I think maybe for their accounting
and you get that daunting paperwork they
send you you know probably because the
Attorney General's
requirements you know so it's been 10
days okay Senator Lang thank you soorry
I think a piece of the question I think
uh representative am had was you I
remember chable gaming when it was Monte
Carlo night right and they would set up
the tables and you'd play local golf
course or something like that and the
charity would collect its funds and they
tear it all back down but the oblig it
was a similar obligation that the
charity would help promote the Monte
Carlo night do you guys do any active
promotions for saying hey this is our
window of time at at a gaming operation
please come support us do do you do do
your Charities do any of that active
promotion to help them oh we don't
okay probably because I didn't think I
should I didn't think of it now that's a
great
idea not that it's required at the lucky
moves but when we know we have our 10
days we flooded all over our Facebook
all of us all of our me there's there's
14 different uh directors we flooded on
that uh saw our social media and ask
everybody to promote it it helps all of
us it's not required but it's something
we make sure we do on a timely basis and
I know one of the groups that we do they
they the groups actually go down and
help help parti ipate just to
help
everything well we've left a lot of
money on the table I think
huh I'm G do that thanks for that
idea the lak reg Casino I echoed their
comments um we were never asked I was
never asked to promote anything about
the Lakes Region Casino um I did promote
it to our alumni in the leadership
program we've got about 46 60 alumni now
in the 25 years and U I sent out an
email saying hey you know here are some
dates I explain what the charitable
gaming rules were and uh how this was a
benefit for us uh I don't know if any of
them took advantage or not but that was
the only promotion we did and it was
initiated by us not by the casino right
okay questions um oh go to I think we've
already
yeah what I'm going to ask again we've
gone over before but basically we have
three Charities here that without the
charitable gaming am I correct in saying
that most
organizations the go-getters if you want
in the
organization if you have a fundraiser
they're there they're devoting their
time to that fundraiser again to really
increase the funds but it's the same
individuals who basically turn around
and provide the service or try to get
the the basic program so that you're
basically burning them out if you've got
to go over and really put their activity
into the fundraising aspect where charel
gaming kind of relaxes that a little
bit it sounds like you know that first
yeah that that's a problem all clubs are
having this it's the 8020 R 20% of the
people do most of the work they'll come
for the fundraiser and it's it's just
been a very difficult time on the
outside fundraising these days and I've
been doing it since 1991 for several
different charities this has definitely
made a difference to keep us active with
the
communities and and I would Echo those
remarks too you know you can't go to the
well too many times you know and if
we're doing something in Vermont or
something like that someone's going to
put on a third party small golf event
for us you can't ask the same people to
go out and get auction items for you for
everything you do you know you burn them
out and people get tired and you can't
keep hitting up uh everyone on your
donor database oh would you attend this
would you attend that would you go to
this would you go to that you know
pretty soon they'll just take us off
their mailing list you know or uh you
know especially emails and everything so
that's a challenge like you said we face
too um good still good morning good
morning thank you for coming here this
morning um do you folks have excess
funds or do you spend your budget every
year from Char
gam we we spend pretty D I have to watch
it real close as we get to the end of
the fiscal year we're lucky if we CT
$2,000 so um if you were to get
additional funds If the ratio of
profitability for chatable gambling were
to increase would you be able to assist
more citizens absolutely positively yes
yes uh and so there's unserved need
that's not met by your
organizations because of funding yes and
let me just give can I give you an
example of that can I speak to that
let's just say in the North Country uh
we all know when you get above the notch
uh weather changes and and wealth
changes yeah a lot of times if we're
trying to fly someone out of Berlin or
clamont or something like that say down
to a Boston or New York hospital because
they've been referred because of a new
clinical trial and for us equity and
access and healthare is Paramount you
know
and it's a different weather system up
there as we all know so might try to
plan a flight you know out of uh
Whitefield you know our Berlin but the
weather precludes us from doing it and
so many times times um we'll give a
person a um a gas guide yeah we'll send
them a gas guide say for $100 for gas
can you drive from there you know down
to conquer or to Manchester to a bigger
airport or lonia where the weather is
more conducive you know when we're not
going to have freezing levels at a th000
feet you know icing issues and stuff
like
that the other big problem we have which
we're working on right now is community
Outreach I mean I if I had a $2 million
budget just for New Hampshire for
community outreach I'd go through it
it's a hardest thing in the world for us
to keep the word out there that we exist
you've probably never even heard of us
you know and so the need to do Outreach
into the communities and not only to the
hospitals but Town Halls police fire
Social Media newspapers I mean it's a
daunting task you know to do that so I I
wish we had triple the money we're
getting from that the gaming you know
it'd be a god what we're getting now is
a godsend and we're extremely extremely
blessed and grateful to have it because
if we were to fly you once or a thousand
times it would never ever ever ever cost
you a penny and we would never accept a
donation from you if we were flying you
some people not many you know would send
a donation to us thank you for flying us
and we send it right back to them we
just void the check and we send it back
to them because this is our time to take
care of you because people when they
call us they're running out of money
they're running out of Hope and they're
running out of time and because of the
co-pays and the deductibles and the out
of pocket pharmaceutical expenses now
here's a new clinical trial or protocol
that could save their life but they just
can't get to it you know and that's what
we commit representative said Thank you
And and thank you all for your
testimony this commission's tasked with
a A list of things that we should look
out and look at and weigh and I'm kind
of curious as much as the perspective of
the percentage that a gaming uh room
brings in more of that percentage going
to Charities
also um unlike what Dawn experienced
with uh Lakes Region a lot of these
operators have a lengthy list of
Charities that are in the queue looking
for those dates and that's something
that we get calls about often enough I
guess what I would wait to especially
with the
substantial component father of your
your charity uh that's very well known
if if we are tasked with whether
to and I'm just theorizing here you know
out loud with a lottery system say
drawing you know blanks for dates for
Charities and you've been a part of
charitable gaming on the Sea Coast for a
long time and a benefit and and the
charity and the endus is you know
listening to the testimony it's
phenomenal but I guess how would you
look at it as Charities as to how we
would deal with as a commission the
problem of Equitable equitable
distribution would it be
something um we should look at and you
also said you'd love to have three times
as much money I'm sure every charity
would would love to have that but we're
we we kind of have a quandry in that
there are a lengthy list of
Charities that are looking to get entry
into this availability uh I'm involved
with some in Salem many of them um and I
I guess what's your perspective how
should we view this should we should we
be looking at maybe from 10 days to 3
days or six days per charity to
distribute that uh
Revenue in a in a different fashion I
guess uh what would your input be should
should we look at a lottery system
should we look at you know the national
profile of a charity or the state
profile of a
charity we're going to have that issue
at the table and it's something that
maybe some of your and and you're
representing you know a number of
different charities but your input May
weigh in here and it's and it's a real
problem that there's going to have to be
some equitable distribution of these
funds to Charities and I know
everybody's protective of their own
Charities but how would you suggest we
best tackle that
subject well um if I could answer maybe
one of the first things now I have not
had time to think of this right so this
is just off the top of my
head I guess I W want look at the length
of time charity has been involved with
charitable gaming in the
State uh the funds they've been
receiving and how those funds impact the
delivery of services by the
charity and
the the depth of impact that charity is
making for granite
status and are we talking
about uh giving XM my dolls to
say Friends of the library you know and
twin you know what impact what need do
they have and what impact is that going
to have in people's lives so being in
healthc care all my life and Healthcare
Ministry we're talking about people's
lives as far as we're
concerned and 40% of the people we fly
are children and of course the rest are
adults and none of these are frivolous
flights you know probably 80% of the
people suffering from cancers and
different types of cancers are rear
diseases and if because of the
relationship we have with the brook and
this commission and the philosophy of
the state we can save hundreds and
thousands of people's lives a year and
over time and bring them a level of hope
that was
unimaginable before they knew about us
to me that's the test on the value of
charitable
giving just a follow up and and I
understand appreciate and agree with you
but here's the problem here's the
quandry I need what I'm looking from you
for from you
is something's going to change I'm not
saying that's going to but in this
scenario something's going to
change less dates the possibility of
having no
dates how do we choose charities in a a
structured format and and you've already
answered some of that what's our best
Avenue to approach this because I'm I'm
not sure and we can probably get it from
the oper is as to how many Charities are
in the queue and I can tell you this
that you're you're uh in nashwa but your
Charities aren't based in
nsha all over
okay I'm I'm aware of many Charities
that that partake in towns that they're
not based in because there's not a
terriable gaming room in every town some
towns or some rooms will favor the
Charities because they're in that town
I'm I'm looking for you to give us a
little input usable input as to where's
the god rails and where where should we
stay as
legislators in in in placing those God
rails because it's brought up many many
times to us that uh it's not necessarily
fair and and you also testified to and I
have it in in the rooms that are in
Salem that have been there since
Inception Charities that have been
the Legacy Charities since the the
beginning of charitable gaming some
would argue well they they've had their
share well is that necessarily Fair too
we we need some real answers some real
honest discussions from the Charities
and every like I said everyone's going
to defend their own but what what's the
best way give us a little input on that
from that perspective let me because I
had a similar kind of a thing so so when
we did the historic Racing We doubled
the number of Charities that involed now
there's two dates it used to be one date
now there's two dates so we were able to
double does your room have historic
racing
yet historic racing yes they do they do
B has social they all three have racing
so here's the issue some of these places
are growing and growing Brook big right
so I'm sure you're reaching 100,000 no
problem in your 10
days um you know and as these places
grow and some of the other ones that are
smaller are are adding and growing as
well so is there a is there going to be
a sealing of the dollar amount because
the Dilemma of us doing something
drastic is that a lot of these Charities
are dependent on this money now it to
try to wean them off this money it's
very very hard so we have to be aware of
that too so but I the way I'm thinking
is we we we may have to put a cap on as
these some of these places grow and grow
if they're going to double their
business business in three years does
that mean that the Charities do we go to
three Charities you know based on you
know you know I'm big on trying to
protect even when we did the the two
dates we we we we took care of trying to
the Legacy Charities to try to make sure
they didn't lose too much when during
that transition
period so I mean would would if we were
to say to you you know out of this
commission you know we're going to we're
going to put a ceiling on it but not
hurt you
where you are I mean so that other
Charities could participate would that
be a reasonable thing to do I think it
would be I do too because that way uh we
could uh and there's no greed you could
tell by that no I mean that way you can
plan on for your budget purposes you
know usually how much You' get in that
year right so you ought to put to help
additional New Hampshire Charities uh
that would be seem very reasonable given
the number of of locations we have in
Hopper that could potentially
open uh they you know there's going to
be opportunity and some of these are
going to grow bigger and bigger um and
that basically the way to handle this is
grow basically growing more
Revenue then we can cap those you know
to a reasonable amount um and then and
then use the rest to maybe give to
create more dates you know for for other
Charities yeah we had uh one of our
volunteers one of our Earth Angels our
ground crew
drivers um who lives in the Nash area
came to me and says gee there a I forget
was in Nash or some other Casino I never
heard of you know I told them all about
Angel Flight and they' like to off you a
week for travel gambling but when they
knew we were getting the Mone from the
BR they couldn't do it because they said
you can only have one a 10day period a
year yeah okay any other real okay sure
good morning gentlemen thank you so much
for your testimony I'm Mark Delano
Assistant Attorney General at the
Department of Justice as you can imagine
our department is interested in things
like accounting and accountability and
so I have a question for each of you
it's a kind of a two-part question first
part is how do you uh treat the monies
that come in from charitable gaming on
your books do they come in as just a
general donation or do you track them as
charitable Gaming revenue in some way
and second part um are you able to track
the dollars that come in from charitable
gaming and see it applied to your
various programs as opposed to things
like marketing and
administration
well a little difficult to answer but
when we have different fundraisers in
our alliance club for example and we we
have a very said budget income and
expenses uh I our Treasurer and
secretary do a great job reporting it
back to the state so it does go on our
our books as terrible gaming auction
whatever it may be and then we have a
budget that basically
just uh we vote on what we're going to
spend through the course of the year and
part of gaming where we did make a lot
more we we took a like $115,000 of what
we made and gave it right to right to
fuel assistance so at the end of the
year we can tell you every dime that we
spent on every charity that it came in I
can't say that that we
Mark uh okay all the gaming money we we
pay for this because it does kind of go
into general fund with other budgets
with with other
fundraises as far as the Ang perspective
too it's pretty much the same thing you
know we uh have a very
sophisticated uh system of
accountability and you know we're a
fourstar charity on charity Navigator
and as donations come in our accountant
our our external CPA and our internal a
bookkeeper has a chat of accounts and is
it a general donation is it a Beque is
it a income from our annual appeal uh is
it money from an event you know uh
that's how we categorize the Monies and
then 100% of our monies go to program
services so we need to recruit Pilots so
a lot of them is pilot Recruitment and
training and you know maintaining their
resources to make sure that they're
current they meet the FAA standards they
meet our standards um that they're safe
to fly you know people and their
families so I think pilot resource
management is very very key for us a
community outreach uh into the area um
and also flight Mission coordination
because we have several full-time people
the 24 hours a day answer the phone and
coordinate all these flights and we have
found
ourselves this past year um more
recently spending thousands of dollars
that we did not anticipate on buying
people airline tickets you know when
Jeff blue doesn't fly that route or the
weather is too bad for our Pilots uh and
pilot of ability is a crucial thing for
us you know 10 years ago we had 1,200
volunteer pilots and now we're down to
450 uh a lot of people have gotten out
of flying especially around Co when they
you know they lost their jobs and they
had to cut back in their expenses or
they have two kids or three kids in
college
now they first stop Flying for us they
were all in grar school they didn't have
these college expenses
so um it's just like the lady from uh
London der you know we're giving her
money we pay for an Uber and then we pay
for a bus trip yeah but I think I think
the question really was about the
process that you go through yeah so we
have a very sophisticated process it's
very detailed and you know highly
accountable right you follow up well
after we're not very sophisticated uh I
enter it in the bank account we have two
accounts I enter it into the bank
account as a donation for example
payment number one Lakes Region Casino
charity gaming and I entered the dollar
amount in the account but then I share
with our board obviously how we're doing
and what that was and we immediately
look at scholarships uh for uh either
people coming into the leadership
program or for the students whose
families simply can't afford the summer
camp the stem summer so we in our heads
earmarked that funding for
scholarships follow up follow up so you
know just based on the operations that
you folks work with or oversee um what
are your thoughts on if the state
required some kind of report uh from
each of your Charities that uh listed on
it where all of the charitable Gaming
revenue went is that something that
would be I guess offensive to your
Charities would it be something that
would be difficult to produce or create
too much administrative
burden well it would
if uh I labor over that annual report
and uh thankfully my wife has an
accounting background and we have a
calculator so we bang it out together uh
but yeah it would be it would be
burdensome but I understand
accountability and if the state required
that we obviously would comply but it it
would be we're all volunteers none of us
gets a paycheck from the organization so
uh but it it would be a little bit of a
burden but time
consuming as far as Angel Flight goes
we're used to that uh we have to give
detailed reports to Jeff blue on all the
vouchers used the patients names the
ticket numbers the traveling uh we have
a large partnership with Lexi
pharmaceutical on rare disease patients
uh that they give us funding for lodging
Transportation stuff like that so we
have to give them extremely detailed
reports and also the main Cancer
Foundation so we have to detail where
where we spend every penny so it would
be another report but if you we'd be
happy to adore
it I guess I'll Echo the other two it's
it's something that I don't think we
would like to see happen but if it did
we could definitely cope with it with
other other fundraisers is coming in we
just have to be more careful how we
separate it and and what we amark what
we it's something we could definitely
do okay any other
questions see none more thank you three
of you very much thank you everybody
appreciate very helpful thank you so
very much and if we can ever be of help
to you guys like you know representative
said un answering some of those
questions you know if you sent us
something we' do our best to respond to
you uh in writing
you
know thank you thank you very much so
we're going to do a little speed dating
here uh the next three items just to
keep the discussion going on on the on
the breakage discussion I'm still not
comfortable that one one of the vendors
is
not contributing to the
fund uh so we I still think we need to
come up with a solution to that um I
know some said well the money's but it's
but the Charities are getting the money
or whatever but I think if if we have a
process we should everybody should be
abiding about the same
process you know and may maybe we just
say we get rid of the breakage part and
and uh and then this other other states
charge the uh equipment people a fee to
do business in the state we don't we
really don't do that right a little bit
little teeny bit no um manufacturers
don't pay a few whatsoever and certainly
I've talked to the manufacturer one
specifically and they'd be happy to pay
a fee versus change their programming uh
and I think fundamentally I think it
makes more sense to do away with
breakage and charge a manufacturers
annual fee but that's that's a
legislative fix yep senator look the
quau is going to be this I think
challenge a you're going to have more
and more machines so the breakage
numbers are going to increase quite
dramatically the more machines you have
the more add of the breakage so it seem
to me that the fee makes
sense because everybody would be paying
this paying the same it's it's how you
going to establish the the fee I think
is is the key item the only thing you
have to go on is what's happened prior
prior to In terms in terms of the
breakage for those who who represent it
now Visa those that that don't but
breakage is a very
significant player in this game
particularly as you add more and more of
the historic RAC machines
right that's I
an
okay again so yeah I think this is an
either or kind of situation conversation
we either do away with breakage as a
whole and either charge them either a
flat fee or a percentage of dgr
percentage of handle and that would if
we did a percentage of dgr percentage of
handle that would adapt based on the
size the industry grows um and the
number as we have more machines and more
things I'm not sure we're really talking
about machines because breakage is
generally out of um yeah so um but again
if as a as that industry grows and we
know that money goes to problem gaming
that money would grow to go to problem
gaming um and I I you know I'm just not
sure if the answer is percentage of
handle or percentage of ggr but that's
the way I would approach it to make it
and just do away with the you know
return breakage Let The Operators do
what they want to do with the breakage
either roll it back into the pool or
whatever they do but
they would have a fixed C they would
have a fixed they would know that I have
to pay you know quarter of a point on
you know on my gross handle to go to
probably damage but again it would be
interesting to uh to find out what other
states do with this I mean there's a
plenty of gambling going on in a lot of
other states uh that they do charge I
know it sounded like they do charge for
the for the vendors to be to to Hardware
the uh uh in our case historic ring to
to pay a
fee substantial fee actually
yeah I mean certainly it varies buying
whether it's a upfront fee to to
business it's a per machine raid if it's
uh Senator Lang suggested a percentage
of tgr certainly a breakage right now
isn't going to the operator in these
context it's going back to the player
base in terms of the the pool so um okay
all right I think we're getting a little
closer here and I think we're um
okay but what I mean by that is the the
weight is now should be changed okay now
how it's going to change we have to fill
in the gaps in the next couple meetings
so um all right uh you know we heard
about opt in opt out now right now in
the pipeline and senators and the chair
and chair over here where are we with um
limiting the number of facilities where
does that all stand I don't know the
different there competing bills or
where are we so we have what was the
bill number you sent back over 112 oh
yeah I think that's so one bit 112 back
over to the Senate we haven't acted on
it yet from the house with the change um
the Senate did pass um I forgot the bill
number I'm drawing blank on it um but
the uh that creates a seven-year
moratorium allows for the incremental
growth um for the applicants that
already have applications in play and
that's passed the Senate I believe
that's over in the house now we should
be going to the house well after after
cross you think well we've been setting
them early so I already have two hous
for for Senate ways of means so I know
we're sending the bills over early so I
don't know where that bill stands in the
house that that Bill had
um the the seven year with the and we
added in municipality piece um on that
bill so municipalities get a certain uh
number of days subm to a charity but
only if there's no charity Avil um for
the days that's how we ended up coming
to an agreement
I can't I just can't remember if there's
a competing Bill well the competing bill
is 112 that I'm holding which is a
permanent I'm not sure you might
remember does that have the incremental
growth in it as well
112 you'll have to explain I hav read
this this other piece so incr what do
you mean incremental well the people I
can't remember whether 112 had the
everybody who already applied up to
October yes it has it is in there as
well so the only difference in between
the 112 then the bill that we sent over
is the man piece and sevene moratorium
as compared to a perent Mortor okay yeah
I'm correct it's year more time is that
up to does that bring us up to about 19
licenses well both bills about to bills
yeah both bills would allow for the I
think Charlie us said there was five
pending applications or something I
don't I don't I don't he changed my
answer so
yeah the an of the room well there's
there's
there's five applications in the process
so we don't know whether
they're yeah up two up two would bring
us up to 20 total and and we're talking
about opt in opt out and that wouldn't
affect any of these applications so what
does it matter I mean going forward if
there's going to be a
7-year moratorium at the that number
yeah we're talking specifically about H
not about future gaming operations then
they're grandfathered into the old
statute
that do not have this requirement of op
asking a community to opt in or out is
that
correct right so then it becomes kind of
moot in the you
know um it's just just the way historic
I mean historic Char game has grown up
never had an optin and out out clause
for communities and it was uh always
handled to some degree through
ordinances in terms of okay you can have
it but you can have it over here not
over
here
just just another uh thing that I became
aware of uh there's a non-gain Amendment
um that's been uh that's being offered
and will be heard by Municipal and
charal gaming in the house um this
Wednesday um I believe representative
Ros for is the prime sponsor of that um
it's under house bill 1223 but it
essentially removes all the wording in
that right using his vehicle and it's uh
it's it's a uh it's a little bit unclear
to me but it it establishes a local
option that applies to horse racing
machines and it also applies to
charitable games games of chance and um
leaves the
Kino system in place so it doesn't
change that um but it essentially allows
for provides for enables a vote at the
Town level to um have or not have these
games just the way I understand the
question is let's say you pass
this um it sounds like that it would not
affect those that are in the pipeline or
do you think it would I don't know it's
a little
unclear what do you think I don't know
has anybody seen
this really what the effective dat is
so the effective dates July 1 2024 which
is the same effective date as
um as the sevene moror bill so right so
this is okay we're not going to solve
this information I have no involvement
in this I just was told thank you for
that though that's great to
know so we'll we that we'll come back to
that next meeting uh I did add one one
that that this is just for us to
consider um I want to learn a little bit
more about license transfer how that
works when a when a facility is
sold
um but trans the company shares are sold
to to all right so the shares are sold
that's what I'm trying to understand
yeah so Shares are sold yes that's the
way that the and the license is part of
the asset right whatever is transferred
whatever is bought as part of that
company that is bought the company that
had a license to
operate the company that operates the
facility is sold to another
entity that's it maintains its license
the license isn't transferred the
corporation owns the license and it's
part of the corporate assets let us take
a real life example conquered conquered
Casino I really wish you didn't oh let's
do that scaring this under the table
over here I've never said it I've never
said it all these meetings I've never
brought them up uh but but but there
there's well all right so Charlie again
if I understand correctly the way it
works is that it again where a business
is the license is an asset of the LLC or
the sorp or the C Corp whatever form of
go business it is yeah if someone buys
that business that's an asset just like
any other asset of the business however
because it's a regulated industry
anybody who buys that uh and has more
than is it 10% 10% or more ownership has
to go through the background checks
Financial checks and everything else so
the newent the new owners have to go
through all of that Rec correct yes they
it's a very as some folks table know
it's a very very lengthy comprehensive
process yes and I I bring it up just for
thoroughness you know something I was
thinking about and I go you know we
should talk about it uh it sounds like
but the vibe I'm getting here is that
people are comfortable with the statute
as it is right now is that Mr chair Okay
no Okay we want the AG put on this so
this is very similar to how
environmental permits work so if if
Senator Lang owned a solid waste
facility and he was going to sell it to
waste management for instance um he
wouldn't sell the asset he'd sell his
entity because that way the dees
permitting would go with it so it's it's
not unlike that um statute scheme right
or I should say regulatory
scheme yeah
representa meeting curious quick
question maybe Charlie can answer do
these buyers because we've seen a few uh
get B bought out do they go through the
process prior to completing the sale
with or is it something they go after
after the fact if I um I don't want to
get to to in the weeds but it's bot
contingent upon their approval
they do expend significant resources
prior to yeah again I've ched many of
these and I I'm always thinking about
the final report and that's in November
but I'm already thinking about it and so
this one you know I want to say that we
discussed this and that we're
comfortable with it I mean it's there
may be this much in the report but that
we touch touch that base now does it
mean we don't discuss it again I think
probably when we write the for we
approve the report that'll be in there
but if anybody has any other issues with
the way this process works you know
bring it up and uh but before now it
sounds like we're we're okay with with
with the current
situation Senator just the current the
current situation still is a bit unclear
to me based on the decision that was
made by the by the individual who who
heard the case
there's an appell process that could be
exercised by the
individual and they have a period of
time which to which to dispose of of the
license now I'm not sure that people I I
didn't understand when you dispose of
the license you're you're disposing of
the
LLC so the you're disposing of the LLC
but within the CL flages of this sale
are all of the amenities that comprise
that
LC
uh
we does does that mean any debt that the
LLC is incurring or or any financial
problems that the LLC has or any legal
problems that the LLC has are all
acquired by the the individual who's
acquiring the
LLC this is a pending matter um so i'
I'm not at Liberty to discuss it in a
public for we I apologize the your
apology is accepted as always you I I'll
consider this not fully closed issue
until hopefully the other matter is
resolved it's still an open question to
me yeah okay okay I'll bring this up in
a couple of meetings from now um so uh
and that anybody have new business they
want to talk about okay next other
businesses to come up with a date for
the the next meeting and I'm going to
recommend you know we're going to run
out of Runway pretty quick I'm telling
you I've done enough of these and we
still haven't gotten the consultant on
board yet so I was just going to say the
one date I'm not available is the 18th
I'm looking at the
25th Monday the
25th I'm gonna try to get this room
again can I bring an air conditioner
yeah no we got open open those windows
it's
a this used to be the Supreme
courtroom yeah I don't know how they
do
yeah yeah that was as of the last uh uh
calendar year yeah so you got calendar
year fiscal year calendar
year um I guess we can
add
how how easy would it be to do the last
12 months at the end of March you know
period like it we have data by month
right if we can get those rolled up
numbers for the for that period from um
you know whole Year's data from uh you
know uh April 1st of last year to March
31st is that possible okay yeah all
right I'll remind you not about March
but we still be in March yeah but but
whenever
you no I mean let's let March close and
then once we have March's data let's go
let's let's look at that for 12 months
going backwards okay is that okay with
you okay all right
thanks all right uh great everybody okay
with 25th all right sounds good we got a
plan uh meeting a jarn thank you all if
our guest is still there thank
you
so I just want to stay in touch with
your